president Trump's planned rally tonight
in Phoenix Arizona is expected to draw
thousands of supporters and protesters
it comes at a time of heightened
political tension in that state now the
president has been at odds with
Arizona's two Republican senators John
McCain and Jeff Flake now the city's
Democratic mayor Greg Stanton is asking
President Trump to delay the rally
following the violence in
Charlottesville Virginia Carter Evans is
out at the convention center in Phoenix
where the president is due to speak
Carter good morning good morning vice
president Pence is also expected to
attend this campaign style rally tonight
now Arizona traditionally leans
Republican local polling puts support
for the president his approval rating at
about 42 percent that is higher than the
national average but there are gonna be
some protesters here tonight you can see
they are already setting up here in the
street there are going to be at least
six protests the largest could draw
about 3,000 people I will assure you
that we are well well-prepared Phoenix
Police Chief Jerry Williams is
reassuring the city that local law
enforcement is ready for president
Trump's downtown rally but given the
violence in charlottesville just ten
days ago in current political tension
here in Phoenix the City's Mayor Greg
Stanton says this is not the right time
for this large-scale political event I
believe the true intention is to really
inflame people's passion to further
divide the country and that's why I said
that the president should delay this
trip to Phoenix a major concern to many
hear reports that the president could
use this rally to pardoned former
Maricopa County Sheriff Joe Arpaio the
controversial lawman is awaiting
sentencing of up to six months in jail
after a federal judge found he broke the
law when his office carried out traffic
patrols that targeted immigrants that
would just you know put gasoline on that
potential flame that would be a really
bad thing not just for Phoenix but for
the entire United States of America
mayor Stanton is among a number of
Arizona politicians currently at odds
with the president including some in his
own party it's a shell of a bill right
now we all know that it
Arizona's Republican Senator John McCain
who provided the crucial no vote that
doomed the Trump administration's effort
to repeal the Affordable Care Act
arizona's other Republican Senator Jeff
Flake has been increasingly vocal in his
criticism of Trump and his policies if
you just have you know erratic behavior
unmoored from principle that's not a
good combination
in a tweet last week Trump called him
weak on borders in crime and toxic while
endorsing his opponent there are going
to be a lot of Trump supporters here
tonight we've already seen some of them
been here since 3 a.m. but before he
comes here the president will be in Yuma
Arizona to visit Customs and Border
Protection there
milt supporters already lining up Carter
thanks